veamos si podemos encontrar el producto
de x menos 4 y voy a poner esto entre
paréntesis queremos encontrar el
producto de x 4 por x + 7 y como siempre
te recomiendo que le pongas una pausa al
vídeo y lo intentes por tu cuenta en fin
hay muchas formas de atacar este
problema de multiplicar estas dos cosas
de aquí pero la forma que a mí me gusta
especialmente si estamos aprendiendo a
hacer esto es darnos cuenta que si
podemos utilizar la propiedad
distributiva que tanto amamos y
conocemos súper bien y cómo hacemos eso
pues tomamos todo el x menos 4 tomamos
todo el binomio y lo distribuimos por
aquí aunque hoy vamos a tomar todo el
binomio y lo multiplicamos por equis y
luego lo multiplicamos por 7 entonces
tenemos que reescribir esto tenemos por
aquí
4 por esta x esta x azul más x menos 4
por 7 nunca y porque estamos
distribuyendo el x menos 4 y lo tenemos
que multiplicar por todos los términos
de este binomio así es que también
tenemos x menos 4 x menos 4 x 7
7 y ahora cuánto va a hacer esto de aquí
pues ahora vamos a multiplicar x por
equis y nos queda x cuadrada y luego la
equis por menos 4 es menos 4x y luego
por aquí distribuyó este 7
7 x x
7 x 7 x menos 4 es menos 28 y ahora
podemos observar que podemos simplificar
un poco más esto de aquí tenemos aquí
dos términos de primer grado son
términos que tienen cierta cantidad de
equis y por lo tanto los podemos juntar
entonces lo que tenemos aquí es x al
cuadrado y luego vamos a combinar estos
dos términos de primer grado y tenemos
menos 4x más 7x y eso va a hacer 3x
aunque hay porque menos cuatro más 7
estrés
y por supuesto aquí tenemos el menos 28
y listo ya terminamos ya multiplicamos
estos dos binomios utilizando únicamente
la propiedad distributiva dos veces
porque hay distribuimos todo el binomio
x menos 4 en x + 7 para obtener x menos
4 por x más x menos 4 por 7 y después
volvimos a utilizar la propiedad
distributiva para multiplicar x x x
menos 4 y obtuvimos lo que tenemos aquí
en amarillo y después distribuimos el 7
en x menos 4 obteniendo lo que tenemos
aquí en verde y finalmente nada más
simplificamos un poquito